.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Die Tür ist offen.
- Die gehen gerade.
Verdammt, wo ist meine Kamera?
So, fertig. Jetzt einfach drauf.
Dieses Mal wird es wohl knapp.
Yeah.
Bingo.
Genau vor mir.
Das ist Timing.
Solche Momente, ob die Observation
super verläuft oder nicht ...
Das sind sehr angespannte
Situationen für mich.
Und wenn man zwischendurch
noch Gas geben muss ...
Da kann man den Führerausweis
gleich zum Fenster rauswerfen.
In diesen Situationen macht es so.
Davon leben wir.
Das ist mein Vater.
Er ist Privatdetektiv.
Nicht einer wie Matula oder Magnum -
er ist echt.
Und in echt ist der Beruf
ziemlich unspektakulär.
Okay - eine Knarre hat er auch.
Also, mehr als eine.
Aber die lässt er schön zuhause.
Statt rumzuballern,
heftet er GPS-Sender an fremde Autos,
filmt heimlich andere Leute
und verfolgt sie durchs Quartier.
Für mich ist er der beste Autofahrer
auf der ganzen Welt.
Sein Job ist oft langweilig.
Tagelang sitzt mein Vater
im verdunkelten Auto.
"Observation" nennt sich das.
Bei Laune hält ihn das Radio.
Schwyzerörgeli ist sein Ding.
* Fröhliche Ländlermusik *
* Er pfeift mit. *
Privatdetektiv ist er seit 32 Jahren.
Fast schon seit ich denken kann.
Eigentlich würde mein Vater
sein Geschäft gerne weitervererben.
Doch ich war immer zu sehr
mit Journalismus beschäftigt.
Vielleicht habe ich da was verpasst.
Als Journalist wollte ich
schon immer mal über ihn berichten.
Aber seriöse Privatdetektive wie er
scheuen Medien
wie der Teufel das Weihwasser.
Googelt man ihn, findet man
weder Gesicht noch Homepage.
Social Media braucht er höchstens
für seine Recherchen.
Nun mit 73 kann er es sich leisten,
nicht mehr im Untergrund zu sein.
Er will mich in die Tricks
seines Business einweihen.
Ich darf ihn als Journalist
mit der Kamera begleiten,
doch diese
muss immer unauffällig bleiben.
Geh weg mit der Kamera.
Schnell runter. Ja.
Nein, schau jetzt da.
Runter mit der Kamera.
Details zu den echten Fällen
dürfen wir nicht erzählen.
Vieles müssen wir unkenntlich machen.
Ich als Sohn
könnte befangener kaum sein.
Dieser Film wird nicht objektiv.
Aber vielleicht finde ich heraus,
ob auch ich
als Privatdetektiv taugen würde.
Merci vielmals.
- Schönen Tag. - Ihnen auch.
Der Tag beginnt mit einem Frühstück
im Auto und einem neuen Auftrag.
80 % der Fälle meines Vaters
kommen von Versicherungen.
Für sie
beschattet er mutmassliche Betrüger.
Ist das ein Auftrag,
bei dem du sagen kannst:
"Da mache ich etwas Sinnvolles?"
Ja, das ist so. Ja.
Es kann unter Umständen
die Öffentlichkeit entlasten.
Weil sie vielleicht
weniger Prämien zahlen muss.
Wenn man einen solchen Betrüger
überführen und entlarven kann ...
... hängt das in der Regel
mit grossen Geldbeträgen zusammen,
die man solchen Personen
dann vielleicht nicht zahlen muss.
Wenn man sie überführen
und zeigen kann,
wie sie betrogen haben.
Das gibt mir die Motivation,
überhaupt an so etwas zu arbeiten.
Wir fahren zum Wohnort einer Frau.
Sie
ist zu fast 100 % krankgeschrieben
und erhält monatlich Geld
von einer Versicherung.
Diese aber hat den Verdacht, dass
die Frau trotzdem voll arbeitet -
in einer Pizzeria.
Der Privatdetektiv
soll dies beweisen. - Verdammt.
Das ist sie ja.
Sie hat sich angeschnallt.
Dann machen wir uns
auch startbereit.
Jetzt fährt sie irgendwo hin.
- Ich wette, die geht ins Geschäft.
Hoffentlich habe ich ...
Jetzt muss ich aufpassen,
dass ich nicht allzu schnell bin.
Ich sehe sie
nämlich dort drüben fahren.
* Telefon *
Uh, jetzt kann ich gerade nicht.
Schatzi, ich kann gerade nicht,
gell? Später. Tschüss.
Nach 20 Jahren Beziehung
weiss seine Lebenspartnerin,
dass sie ihn auf der Jagd
nicht stören darf.
Jetzt hat sie wohl Grün,
jetzt hat sie Grün.
Und ich habe ein kleines Kind.
Komm.
Wenn sie merken,
dass sie überwacht werden ...
... muss man die Übung blitzartig
abbrechen und nach Hause gehen.
Und den Auftraggeber anrufen
und sagen:
"Sorry, es ging in die Hose."
"Ich bin verbrannt."
"Sie haben mich bemerkt.
Ich muss aufhören."
Aber so weit sollte es nicht kommen.
So weit
kommt es etwa im Jahr einmal.
Das ist für mich der Super-GAU.
So, jetzt da vorne.
Ah. Schau, sie fährt rein.
Wenn sie
eine gewisse Zeit arbeitet ...
... hat sie ihr Pensum ...
... das sie vielleicht arbeiten
dürfte, sicher schon erreicht.
Oder eben schon mehr.
Hunderte Betrüger
hat er schon überführt.
Für die Versicherungen
ist er der zuverlässige Mann
für die Arbeit im Feld.
Heute hat er die Frau
4 Std. bei der Arbeit beobachtet.
In ein paar Tagen
werden wir wiederkommen.
Am nächsten Morgen
wartet ein anderer Auftrag.
Um 5 Uhr
holt mich mein Vater zu Hause ab.
Also, wir fahren los.
- Yes.
Tipptopp.
Wenn ich Erfolg haben will,
muss ich meine Arbeitszeiten
der Kundschaft und dem Fall
anpassen.
Heute geht es
um ein zwischenmenschliches Drama.
Auch dies ein Klassiker
für einen Privatdetektiv:
eine gescheiterte Beziehung.
Der Ex-Freund einer Frau will wissen,
wo sie heute wohnt
und wer ihr neuer Freund ist.
Denn der Mann selber darf sich
der Frau nicht mehr annähern.
Deshalb engagiert er
einen Privatdetektiv.
Ein heikler Auftrag.
Da könnte man sich
fast schon Gedanken darüber machen,
ob man diesen Fall
annehmen möchte oder nicht.
Offenbar
haben sich diese zwei Personen
im Milieu kennen gelernt.
Man muss aufpassen, dass man nicht
selber in ein Fettnäpfchen tritt -
z.B. einer Person Beweise beschafft,
die sie dann
illegal weiterverwenden will.
Wow!
Du bist nicht wild darauf -
ist das eher ein Scheissauftrag?
Ja, das geht in die Kategorie
"Aufträge von Privatpersonen".
Das ist meistens etwas heikel.
Man muss mit diesen Leuten
zuerst einen Vertrag abschliessen.
Dann muss man schauen,
dass man zu seinem Geld kommt.
Wenn nicht
das erhoffte Resultat rauskommt ...
... könnten sie sich
unter Umständen weigern zu zahlen.
120 Fr. pro Stunde:
Meinen Vater zu engagieren,
kostet schnell mal mehrere 1'000 Fr.
Ich fahre jetzt mal vorbei.
Jetzt müssen wir uns
einfach ganz unauffällig verhalten.
Dann schalte ich mal das Licht aus.
- Mhm.
Da ist bereits eine Frau,
die mit einem Hund spaziert.
Das sind genau die, die alles sehen.
Das ist das Haus. Der Eingang
ist offenbar auf dieser Seite.
Was machst du, wenn die Person kommt,
der dieser Parkplatz gehört?
Dann verziehe ich mich blitzartig,
damit sie hinkann.
Und ... Kein Problem.
Dann verschwinde ich einfach.
Ich entschuldige mich,
wenn es nötig ist,
sodass ich keine Probleme kriege.
Schau, jetzt kommt schon ...
Uh.
Morgen.
Die stört uns nicht.
Sie wohnt nicht im gleichen Block.
Zudem bin ich hier
relativ unverdächtig, denke ich.
* Pfeifen *
Die Umgebung machen wir unkenntlich,
um Betroffene zu schützen.
So.
- Und?
Ja ...
Es ist so ... Oh, die Sonne blendet.
Die Frau wohnt da, das ist so.
Das ist angeschrieben.
Aber nur ihr Name,
an der Klingel, wie am Briefkasten.
Da ist keine zweite Person.
Es sieht wirklich so aus,
als ob sie allein wohnen würde.
Also, jetzt gehe ich nach hinten.
Das sind so Turnübungen,
die man halt einfach machen muss.
Mein Vater will nun
ein paar Stunden vor dem Haus warten
und die Frau beim Rausgehen filmen -
wobei er sie nur von Fotos kennt.
Wenn gewisse Bedürfnisse aufkommen
und man pinkeln gehen muss,
nehmen wir unser WC hervor:
diese Büchse hier.
Da wohnen jetzt sechs Parteien.
Wenn man die Leute nicht kennt,
ist es schwierig zu wissen,
wer es ist.
Darum filme ich jetzt alle,
die rauskommen.
Jetzt
kommt tatsächlich eine Frau ...
Sie hat gerade ...
... mit dem Velo ...
Eine Prachtsaufnahme ist es nicht.
Aber wenn ich sie vergrössere ...
Doch, sollte eigentlich gehen.
Da drüben kommt jetzt
eine Frau mit einem Hündchen.
Die macht ihre Runde.
Das könnte sie sein.
Während wir stundenlang
aus dem Fahrzeug filmen,
wird mir klar,
dass unsere Jobs sehr ähnlich sind.
Als TV-Journalist ist es auch mein
Business, andere Leute zu filmen.
Genau wie mein Vater,
suche auch ich als Reporter
immer ein kleines Abenteuer.
Das ist definitiv illegal.
- Nein, nein, das ist erlaubt.
Von mir aus können wir.
Die Arbeit von Reporter und
Privatdetektiv ist fast dieselbe:
Sie gehen raus,
sie filmen, sie recherchieren
und holen Informationen ein.
Am Ende fertigen sie daraus
einen Bericht und liefern diesen ab.
Bloss sind meine Berichte
für ein Publikum bestimmt.
Normalerweise bin ich im Bundeshaus.
Im Vergleich zu Privatdetektiven
stehen Bundeshausjournalisten
in der Öffentlichkeit.
Verstecken geht nicht.
Das hat mich etwas enttäuscht,
muss ich fairerweise sagen.
Nicht einmal, 0,0.
Sie haben sich schon mal
bei mir beschwert.
Das ist ein guter Journalist.
Der ist in Ordnung.
Da ist nicht jeder derselben Meinung.
Ich sag es einfach.
- Ist gut.
Das hat mich mitgenommen,
das Staatsfernsehen.
Manchmal denke ich, mein Vater
hätte auch Journalist werden können.
Oder ich vielleicht Privatdetektiv.
Du wärst eigentlich
ein guter Journalist geworden.
Ja, ich könnte eigentlich
auch Investigativjournalist sein.
Du könntest es aber auch sein.
Rein theoretisch
könntest du meine Firma übernehmen
und einfach weitermachen.
Bis jetzt
habe ich ja keinen Nachfolger.
Ich habe mich entschlossen,
diese Firma bis
zu meinem stillen Ende zu behalten.
Aber wer weiss,
vielleicht tut sich da ja
noch eine Alternative auf, gell.
Während zehn Jahren war er Präsident
des renommiertesten Berufsverbandes
Schweizer Privatdetektive.
Volles Engagement für den Job:
Das hat er mir vererbt.
Auch mit 73
bleibt er hartnäckig dran -
bis das Glück des Tüchtigen
ihn findet.
Ah doch.
Jetzt ist die Balkontür offen.
Das finde ich jetzt gut.
Also: Balkontür ist offen.
- Sie ist also zu Hause.
Jemand ist da.
Jetzt muss ich schauen, ob ich
allenfalls noch einen Platz finde.
Von da drüben ...
Ja, von da könnte es gehen.
Puh.
Es wäre schön,
wenn ich sie auf dem Balkon sähe.
Ich gehe wieder nach hinten.
Ja, direkte Sicht.
Ja, ich habe sie.
Sie hat ganz kurz
einen Müllsack rausgebracht.
Es ist nicht viel, aber
ich habe sie. Ich habe sie. Fertig.
Da schneide ich einen Teil raus,
mache ein schönes Foto,
vergrössere und bearbeite es.
Und das ist sie.
Wenn wir Glück haben, kommt sie
wirklich mit einem Mann raus.
Hast du deine Kamera ...
- Oh, schau. Verdammt, sie ist dort.
Jetzt geht sie hinters Haus.
Sie kommt sicher mit einem Velo.
Scheisse, scheisse.
Das ist jetzt ein Notfall.
Das ist sie, ja.
Sie nimmt
noch den Müllsack mit raus.
Okay.
Siehst du, da habe ich sie schön.
Mal so ...
Tipptopp.
Die Frau macht eigentlich
einen seriösen Eindruck.
Das muss ich sagen.
Im Vergleich zu deinem Auftraggeber?
- Das hat was, ja.
Also, ich habe sie tipptopp drauf.
Ich muss mir überlegen,
wie es weitergeht.
Ich möchte mit ihm sprechen.
Ich möchte
auf der sauberen Seite bleiben.
Etwas anderes kommt nicht infrage.
Ja.
Also,
jetzt trinken wir einen Kaffee.
Zurück im Büro
zeigt er mir seine Spezialwerkzeuge -
etwa eine ganze Reihe Mikrokameras.
Es gibt eine Minikamera
in einem Feuerzeug,
in einem Autoschlüssel,
in einem falschen Kugelschreiber
oder in einer dicken Uhr.
Und natürlich
die klassische Knopflochkamera.
In diesem Schrank
lagert das Geschäftsgeheimnis:
Diese schwarzen Klumpen
sind GPS-Tracker.
Dank Magneten haften diese an Autos.
Sie haben eine SIM-Karte
und senden bis zu drei Monate lang.
Die Position von Fahrzeugen kann
mein Vater so jederzeit mitverfolgen.
Einen solchen Tracker
wollen wir heute anbringen.
5 Uhr morgens.
Der eifersüchtige Ex der Frau,
die wir vor ihrem Haus gefilmt haben,
hat die Adresse des mutmasslichen
neuen Lovers geliefert.
Mein Vater soll rausfinden,
ob er tatsächlich
der neue Partner der Frau ist.
Musik aus.
(Flüsternd)
Leck mir doch alles am Arsch.
Es ist dort, das hintere Haus.
Jetzt mache ich noch den Klassiker:
Ich nehme eine Hundeleine mit
und hänge mir sie um.
Dann ist die Ausrede,
dass mir der Hund entlaufen ist.
Und dass ich ...
... denke, er sei unter das Auto.
Es sei nur ein kleines Hündchen.
- Ja.
Tanja heisst sie.
Also, ich bin weg.
- GutesGelingen. - Merci.
Ich bewundere
den Draufgänger in meinem Vater.
Und den Nervenkitzel in seinem Job -
den würde ich auch mögen.
Und?
Es ist nicht da.
Das Auto ist nicht da.
Das Kontrollschild ist nicht da.
Schöne Scheisse.
Das ist jetzt wirklich nicht gut.
Warum ist das nicht gut?
Also ...
Der Mann, um den es geht ...
... von dem ich die zwei Autos
und das Kontrollschild habe,
ist nicht hier.
Das sind andere Fahrzeuge.
Was machen wir jetzt?
Wir gehen zu seinem Arbeitgeber
und müssen dort weiterschauen.
Das ist einfach so.
Jetzt müssen wir versuchen,
den Mann um 6 Uhr morgens
bei seiner Arbeit zu finden,
um sein Auto dort
mit einem Peilsender zu versehen.
Das ist die Firma.
Das hier gehört alles dazu.
Verdammter Scheissdreck.
Ich darf nicht
einfach in die Halle reinfahren.
Aber schauen
gehe ich jetzt trotzdem.
Ich habe mich
sonst einfach verfahren.
Ups, das ist er.
Das war er.
Da hänge ich jetzt
nicht einfach so ein Gerät dran.
Wir warten ab.
Der Mann wird das Gelände wohl
mit einem Firmenfahrzeug verlassen.
Dann wäre die Luft rein, um an
seinem Auto den Tracker anzubringen.
Ich glaube, das ist er.
Also ...
Wir schauen und versuchen es.
Scheisse.
Das ist eine Riesenscheisse.
Uff, da sind noch Leute.
Es ist ein hohes Risiko.
Ich mache es nicht.
Gottverdammt noch mal.
Da drüben sind auch Leute.
Und ein Hund. Himmelsternen.
Wenn ich mich auf den Boden lege ...
Hach. Mhm.
Diese Frau schaut bestimmt rüber.
Da muss ich
wohl den anderen Trick anwenden.
Sicher bin ich noch nicht.
Nicht nur eine Hundeleine,
auch eine Getränkeflasche gehört in
die Trickkiste von Privatdetektiven.
Als sog. Legende, also als Ausrede,
um unter fremde Autos zu kriechen.
Jetzt ist mir
diese Flasche runtergefallen ...
Also, das Gerät ist dran.
Gut.
Es ist, wie es ist.
Das Gerät ist dran, fertig.
Ohne Fleiss kein Preis.
Das lief jetzt wirklich optimal.
Zuerst war quasi ...
Erst wussten wir nicht, wo was ist.
Jetzt hat er das Gerät am Arsch.
Ziel erreicht. Besser geht es nicht.
Das ist einfach so.
Ja.
Ist es legal, so ein Gerät
an ein Auto zu befestigen?
Das ist im rechtlichen Grenzbereich.
Aber ich schaue es als legal an.
Es könnte
höchstens eine Strafanzeige geben,
wegen Verletzung
der Privatsphäre einer Person.
Aber man weiss ja nicht mal,
wer im Auto sitzt und fährt -
ob meine Zielperson
oder seine Frau oder sein Sohn.
Das ist das vierte Gerät,
das im Moment bei mir läuft.
Man kann sagen: Das Geschäft läuft.
- Gut.
Das GPS zeigt:
Der Überwachte scheint überhaupt
nichts mit der Frau zu tun zu haben.
Ein Reinfall für den Auftraggeber,
ein gelungener Auftrag
für meinen Vater.
GPS-Tracker am Auto
von mutmasslichen Liebhabern -
das kann ja nicht legal sein.
Zurück auf der Redaktion
will es der Journalist in mir
genauer wissen.
Ich rufe
verschiedene Rechtsprofessoren an.
Mit Privatdetektiven
kennt sich kaum jemand aus,
denn diese bewegen sich gekonnt
in rechtlichen Grauzonen.
Schlussendlich aber finde ich
Rechtsexpertinnen und -experten,
die sich intensiv
mit der Branche befasst haben.
Ist der Einsatz von GPS-Geräten
legal?
Der Einsatz von GPS-Geräten
ist strafbar.
Geht es darum, eine geschiedene Ehe-
frau und ihren Freund zu beobachten,
sehe ich
keine mögliche Rechtfertigung.
Es ist eine klare, widerrechtliche
Persönlichkeitsverletzung.
Im Sozialversicherungsrecht hat man
das ausgesprochen genau geregelt:
Will man ein GPS-Gerät
für die Ortung einsetzen,
braucht es einen richterlichen
Beschluss, der das genehmigt.
Ausserhalb davon sind
die Erkenntnisse nicht verwertbar.
Was ist Ihr gesamthafter Eindruck
dieser Branche?
Der Privatdetektive?
Soll ich es wirklich sagen?
- Gerne.
Aber trifft Sie das nicht?
Ich bin bei der Arbeit.
Auf gut Deutsch
sind das nützliche Idioten.
Diese Branche
bewegt sich schon immer
in diesem dunkelgrauen
bis schwarzen Bereich
und lebt auch weiterhin davon.
Meine Vermutung wäre, dass Ihr Vater
sich mehr auf der illegalen Seite
bewegt als auf der legalen.
Hm!
Dass mein Vater immer schön im grauen
bis dunkelgrauen Bereich operiert,
war mir immer klar.
Dass aber
praktisch alles illegal sein soll,
ist nun trotzdem ein Schock.
Verschiedene Rechtsprofessoren
sagen mir,
dass da doch ziemlich vieles
illegal ist, rein rechtlich gesehen.
Wenn ich mir überlegen würde,
in das Geschäft einzusteigen -
das wäre mir zu heiss.
Verstehst du das?
Ja.
Das kann ich
ein Stück weit verstehen.
Die Meinungen,
die du eingeholt hast, von ...
... Rechtsgelehrten sind gut und
recht, aber das sind Theoretiker.
Die haben von Praxis keine Ahnung.
Da sieht es anders aus:
Bei einer Observation
kann es ein gesunder Mix sein
von klar vorgegebenen Massnahmen,
bis zu - unter Umständen -
kleineren Überschreitungen,
etwa im Strassenverkehr.
Aber dass ich mich
ständig im illegalen Bereich bewege,
das ist Mumpitz.
Das ist eine Zumutung,
wenn ich so beschuldigt werde.
Das stimmt einfach nicht.
- Du bist also meistens ...
... im grünen Bereich, auf der
richtigen Seite des Gesetzes? - Klar.
Sonst könnte ich auch nicht
für Versicherungen arbeiten.
Die können ja nicht
illegal erworbene Beweismittel
vor Gericht bringen.
Das ginge ja gar nicht.
Was legal ist und was nicht,
sollte er eigentlich bestens wissen.
Von 1977 bis 1990
war mein Vater 13 Jahre lang
bei der Kantonspolizei Bern.
Vom Dorfpolizisten hat er sich
hochgearbeitet zum Fahnder.
Bei
der Spezialobservationsgruppe Milan
liess er etwa Drogendealer
oder Einbrecherbanden auffliegen.
Ich vermute,
Ex-Polizisten fühlen sich
ihr Leben lang immer etwas im Recht.
Meinem Vater ist bewusst, was droht,
wenn er mit GPS-Geräten bei
privaten Aufträgen erwischt würde.
Da müsstest du
ein paar hundert Franken Genugtuung
bzw. Schadenersatz bezahlen.
Richtig, ich würde wegen Verletzung
der Privatsphäre verurteilt.
Aber das ist ja kein Verbrechen.
Das wäre dann nur eine Übertretung
oder ein Vergehen, mehr nicht.
Okay.
Mein Vater ist ein Schlitzohr.
Er dehnt den rechtlichen Rahmen
gekonnt bis zur Schmerzgrenze.
Ein moralischer Balanceakt -
mir wäre dabei unwohl.
Als Journalist
muss oder darf ich mich
an ein gewisses Arbeitsethos halten.
In Vaters Fussstapfen zu treten,
wäre zudem für mich -
ohne Polizeierfahrung -
ein ziemlich riskantes Unterfangen.
Kaum eine Observation
ohne gesetzliche Grenzgänge.
Ich muss etwas tauchen.
Heute filmt mein Vater
erneut die Frau,
die eigentlich kaum arbeiten kann.
Diesmal beim Pizza ausliefern.
Das ist eine ziemliche Ladung.
Die rennt auch noch ums Auto rum.
Jetzt fährt sie sicher wie eine Sau.
Da muss ich aufpassen.
Ja, genau. Scheisse.
Das reicht wohl nicht.
Ich kann da vorne auch nicht
wie ein Idiot durchfahren.
Sonst falle ich auf.
Da vorne habe ich sie gesehen.
Da muss ich
leider auch noch kurz mit.
Komm, mach grün.
Mannomann.
Da kannst du auf den Mond und zurück
und hier ist immer noch Rot.
Das ist ein Scheiss, ein verdammter.
Es geht wohl nicht mehr so weit
mit dieser Ladung.
Diesmal will ich es nicht verkacken.
Ja.
* Pfeifen *
Kommt nichts, gut.
Ja.
Ich sah sie noch einsteigen.
Dann ging ich
auf die andere Strassenseite ...
... von wo ich sie
ziemlich schön sah.
Bei Rot drüber, aber nur zu Fuss?
Ah, ja. Jaja.
Aber ich habe geschaut,
ob etwas kommt
und ob ich
jemanden gefährde oder nicht.
Es kam niemand.
Gefährdest du dich manchmal selber
bei diesem Job?
Das noch am ehesten. Das ist so.
Ich muss Holz anfassen:
In diesen vielen Jahren habe ich
jede Menge Parkbussen erhalten
und Rotlichter überfahren.
Das kann man alles
mit Geld wiedergutmachen.
Aber einen Unfall, bei dem
Menschen zu Schaden kamen ...
... hatte ich keinen bis jetzt.
Null.
Da bin ich sehr stolz drauf.
Vielleicht hat diese Frau
ja nicht um so viel Geld betrogen.
Bemitleidest du sie nicht?
- Nein, da habe ich kein Mitleid.
Ob es um riesige
oder kleinere Beträge geht:
Sie macht einen Betrug,
wenn sie das macht.
Sie betrügt jemanden.
Diese Einstellung ist verwerflich.
Da wüsste ich nicht,
warum ich Mitleid haben sollte.
Definitiv Nein.
Auf Dreh realisiere ich:
Genau wie ich, geht mein Vater
immer schön ans Limit.
32 Jahre ging das gut -
er blieb unbemerkt.
Bis zu diesem Film.
Mit 73
möchte er langsam kürzertreten.
Ich hoffe, ich bereite seiner
Karriere nicht ein abruptes Ende,
denn sein Gesicht
ist nun kein Berufsgeheimnis mehr.
Für einen Privatdetektiv
ist das ein Problem.
Wird dieser Film dich den Job kosten?
Das hoffe ich nicht.
Aber es könnte passieren. Ja.
Und das nimmst du in Kauf?
- Das nehme ich in Kauf.
Das ist eine neue Erfahrung.
Es ist ein Experiment.
Ich werde immer Privatdetektiv sein,
aber vielleicht einer,
der keine Aufträge mehr hat.
Ich selber werde wohl besser nicht
Privatdetektiv.
Aber ich hoffe, er kann es
trotz dieses Films bleiben.
Wir haben beide einen Job,
den wir lieben.
Tauschen möchte ich nicht.
Umso mehr fasziniert er mich -
mein Vater, der Privatdetektiv.
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
puretype gmbh - 2022